what I've asked you to integrate for the
first one is 2x squared DX
2x squared DX now you can see the two
things that happened here the power I
should say the index was increased right
so straight are three here and what
happens there three what do we do with
it immediately yeah we we divide by that
right I witness to come from where's the
two from the the two was already there
just like with differentiation since
integrations the reverse of that that
two at the front kind of we can put to
one side that coefficient we can just
sort of disregard it briefly and then
put it back when we're done last step
and we've done it to all of them but
plus say what we call that again it's
got a special name it's the constant of
integration because that's what we're
dealing with here and it always needs to
a pleat up here okay as soon as you do
the integration it doesn't appeal like
on the very last line after I've
simplified and cleaned up everything it
appears right away okay looking good for
a Part B now this was a bit sneaky
because I threw a different pronumeral
at you I threw you an A instead of an X
but you know we've been dealing with
functions for what years now but they
don't have to have X's in them they can
have any letter we like they just kind
of stand there as a more they're a
printing rule to put in place of some
numbers so when we have a look at this
one-sixth outside of the 3a minus one
squared who wrote their answer exactly
like that
hands up - okay so I'm interested thank
you hands down most of you most of you
did not report a problem with this but
most of you also didn't raise your hand
and say you wrote your answer like that
so how did you write your answer anyone
want to throw us their idea go ahead
what
[Music]
fantastic okay did anyone write their
answer like this is this answer the same
or is it different it's the same yeah
we've just written the six a different
spot
very few people put up their hand for
that one who wrote the answer another
way still I'm just gonna write a is that
okay yep
yes see who wrote they're also like that
okay a few more hands this seemed like
the most common one yeah or a slight
difference 3 a squared on - yeah okay
which is matches how you did this
okay I'm gonna ask the question again is
this different or is it the same hmm now
it's a bit tricky because it's not
immediately apparent you have to kind of
expand this to see can we just quickly
check this 3a squared or is going to be
9 H squared so I should take 3a all
squared that's 9 a squared what's the
next term when I expand - - I'm just
expanding this thing here it's it's
double the product in the middle right
yep so that's minus 6a are you okay with
that and then the last term alone plus
one okay now when you have a look at it
this whole thing we're saying is divided
by six and then your plus C now if do
they look the same
are you happy with that okay is one I
mean I've got one two three four answers
on the board is one of them better than
any of the others I'd say that roughly
all look pretty equivalent to me
personally when I was writing my own
solutions to this
I wrote this one a reason being I said
well look I can go turn by turn I can go
turn my turn and I can integrate each
one one at a time and that was the least
brain space in my head we have a name
for this approach here these two right
but we'll come to that in a second in
case you can't remember it because a lot
of you went the other way all right lots
you raise your hands for C and
admittedly it was a bit rude of me to
throw this curveball right in the middle
what is integration me
what idea of we connected it to
integration is the opposite of
differentiation right so when we ask you
know can you integrate this right what
we're asking is can you give me that
function which if you differentiate this
you will end there does that make sense
if you differentiate this thing if we've
done it right we should end at whatever
that function is by the way that
function being integrated it has a name
when you see something like this rather
than calling it the function that keeps
being integrated you can call it its
technical name if you like which is an
integrand but honestly it's quite
uncommon so very few people know even
very few textbooks actually say it but
I'm going to say it now because we keep
on referring to it if I differentiate
this if I've got this right I should get
to that integrand does that make sense
it does take a bit of memory because we
haven't been in exponential log land but
we're going to fix that in about an hour
to remember that the derivative of the
natural log that's really important by
the way the natural log so it has to
have a base of e we'll take you to one
over in this case Y or one over X or
whatever T or whatever you have okay and
for this last one I'm actually going to
keep pausing it we will come back to it
shortly
so if you haven't already key please
make this heading there is a conspicuous
blank space here which we will fill
shortly and but what I wanted to remind
all of you we've already sort of looked
at it in these starter questions is
everything that we know at least so far
and for a decent chunk of time
everything we know about integration is
going to be built off it's going to be
hung off what we know about
differentiation does that make sense so
we've already established this rule I
just wanted to see if you remember it
name my colors for this bit orange mmm
since we know that when you're
differentiate a power right we do these
two things number one we we
differentiate by bringing that index out
the front and then what's the second
thing we do we we we subtract one from
the index we reduce the index by one
okay so there are these two acts here
therefore we can say that the opposite
of that to undo that we
undo both of these two actions right so
since the most the last thing that we
did was we are reduce the index by one
what's the first thing we should do here
we should we should do the opposite
which is increase the index does that
make sense you see that corresponds that
action then then the other thing we had
to undo was we multiplied by this index
well what should I do to undo that I
should divide and I should divide by
this new index right you're happy with
that and plus one in this case so I hope
and if you've got colors there this will
really help I want you to see each of
those things undoes a specific thing
there you go and then our last step
which we've already seen a bunch of
times we have to add the constant of
integration and can you remind me what's
the reason for that it's not just random
it's okay so whoopsie Daisy flying what
then Walker
let's say that again so I'm gonna put
both those answers ago perfect we had
plus 5 or plus 2 or a minus you know a
thousand 10,000 whatever right all that
does is that moves the function up and
down right which doesn't change the
gradient which is what this is really in
in Reverse asking okay so all of these
guys would differentiate to give us that
integrand okay